So now we have seen that we really want to have a better predictor, but
the question is how. We have seen that the predict,
taken predictor computes the next PC as a function of the current PC,
by just incrementing it. So question is, if all we know is the current PC,
is there any better function that we can use to form a better prediction
of what's coming next? And the answer is, if all you know is the current PC,
then probably you cannot make much of a better prediction. It will help us,
if we knew, is the instruction a branch. But we don't know that,
we're still fetching the instruction while we are making the prediction.
Is this instruction going to be taken, as a branch? Again, we have no clue about
that. What is the offset field of the instruction? If this is a branch,
this is what will be added to the PC to form the target address if it's taken.
But we don't know that either because we haven't fetched the instruction. So
really, we don't know for sure anything that might be really useful in
forming the [UNKNOWN] prediction. So it seems like it's hopeless, but it's not.
So what do we know if we don't know anything for certain. What we do know
is what the current PC is. But we also know something about how that branch at
this PC was behaving in the past. And we can use that because it turns out
that branches tend to behave the same way over and over again. So really that
is what we can use. We don't know for sure what this branch is going to do but
we can know what it did the few previous times when it was executed.